In 2014, Russian President Vladimir Putin
was not very popular among Republicans or
Democrats.
Which made sense given that he's a somewhat murderous
strongman with the nasty habit of invading his neighbors.
This is, without question, our number one geopolitical foe.
Breaking news, signs of a Russian invasion
in Ukraine tonight.
Since 2000, 25 journalists have died under
mysterious circumstances.
The Russian military campaign in Syria after
a week of airstrikes now escalating dramatically
to prop up Syrian president Assad.
This chart
shows Putin’s net favorability among Republicans.
That's the percentage of people who view him favorably
minus the
percent who view him unfavorably.
You can see the net favorability
begin to rise steadily through 2014 and 2015,
and then, all of a sudden, in August 2016,
it spikes.
By December 2016, the share of Republicans
who saw Putin favorably had more than tripled.
His popularity fell among Democrats, but by a smaller margin. So, what’s going on here?
And what does it mean for the United States’
relationship with Russia?
What I think you're seeing is two years of constant Republican
propaganda about how Vladimir Putin is a strong leader.
Putin decides what he wants to do and he does
it in half a day...He makes a decision and
he executes it, quickly, then everybody reacts.
That’s what you call a leader. People are
looking at Putin as one who wrestles bears
and drills for oil.
They look at our president as one who wears
mom jeans.
What you see is this Republican talking point
that builds and builds and builds, and finally
really hits a peak with Donald Trump.
I think I’d get along very well with him.
I respect Putin.
He’s a strong leader.
If he says great things about me I’m going
to say great things about him.
I’ve already said, he is very much of a
leader.
I mean you can say, “Oh isn’t that a terrible
thing.”
The man has very strong control over a country.
What we're seeing with Donald Trump is that
he believes in the "Great Man Theory" of history,
both the great part of it and also the man
part of it.
He's a man who sees himself as a tough decisive
leader, authoritarian if necessary but willing
to do whatever it takes to push through what
he thinks needs to be done.
He looks to Vladimir Putin in Russia, someone
who has made clear, if you're a dissident
who criticizes him you may disappear, if you're
someone in the public who isn't fully in support
of him, you may lose your job.
And he looks at that and thinks, it works.
There's also a financial connection.
Trump has had trouble getting
loans from US banks following his multiple
bankruptcy filings since 1991.
We know from a speech his son, Donald Jr.,
made in 2008 that Russian investors have played
a big role in financing Trump projects since.
Most wealthy Russian business people maintain
warm relationships with Putin, who holds absolute
power in the country.
That means the investors who helped save Trump’s
business empire are likely to include several
close Putin allies.
We're in this extraordinary moment when a US President
is potentially financially beholden to an enemy country led by a dictator.
There's an intelligence report
in which a former British spy claims the Russian
government has compromising information on
Trump that they could use to blackmail him.
This isn't Hollywood, this isn't conspiracy,
this isn't paranoia, this may actually on
some level be true.
Republican voters may be taking their cues from Trump when it comes to Putin, but Republican lawmakers
are a different story.
Vladimir Putin is a person who's killed.
He's jailed and murdered journalists, political opponents.
Putin is an aggressor that does not share
our interests.
Vladimir Putin is violating the sovereignty
of neighboring countries.
It certainly appears he is conducting in state-sponsored
cyber attacks on what appears to be
our political system.
The Russians undermining democracy throughout the entire world.
They're taking land owned by others by force.
They did hack into our political system, they're doing it to other political systems.
Before he was Donald Trump’s Vice President, then-Representative Mike Pence held
a similar position.
And now an increasingly antagonistic
Russia has been rewarded for bullying and
threatening its neighbors.
Seven years later, he was singing a different
tune.
I think it’s inarguable that Vladimir Putin
has been a stronger leader in his country
than Barack Obama has been in this country.
When Trump praises Putin, he’s also flouting
his party’s long history of skepticism toward Russia.
When you think of Republicans and the kind
of leader they venerate, it's Ronald Reagan.
They come back to Reagan again and again and
again.
I remember when Ronald Reagan was the president.
He stood on principle standing up to the Soviet
Union.
Ronald Reagan reignited the American economy,
rebuilt the military, bankrupted the Soviet
Union and defeated Soviet communism.
And they come back to him because they think
he won the Cold War, and because they think
he beat the Soviet Union.
The march of freedom and democracy which will
leave Marxism-Leninism on the ash heap of
history as it has left other tyrannies which
stifle the freedom and muzzle the self-expression
of the people.
This is not just a break from Republicans
on the Hill in 2016, this is a break with
the last 30 years of ideology, dating back to a President,
Ronald Reagan, who they hold up as a near god-like figure.
Trump has also been slow to accept the CIA
and FBI’s conclusion that Russia sought
to influence the Presidential election.
Russia hacked the Democratic National Committee Servers,
it hacked the personal email of John Podesta, Hillary Clinton's campaign chairman
As far as hacking I think it was Russia, but I think we also get hacked by other countries and other people.
Vladimir Putin weaponized the fact that we
have a free press.
He used Wikileaks to kind of launder the information,
and then dribbled it out day by day by day.
So for weeks, in the run up to the election,
all you saw was negative press coverage of
Hillary Clinton driven by selectively chosen
leaked emails.
In response, President Obama issued economic
sanctions against Russia,
which Donald Trump doesn't have to keep
These were weak, these sanctions, they're
gonna do nothing.
Vladimir Putin will look at this and
say, I got what I wanted, I can pay this cost,
I'll do it again.